ladies gentlemen we had no idea this
event was going on today but hey they
have this ps5 Hart Hardware reveal
trailer
so let's actually check out what's going
on with the console today ladies and
gentlemen it's John's birthday tomorrow
so he's taking the day off and we're
sticking to that so whatever else we got
to catch up on do it on Saturday
hopefully we have time because we got
some patreon TV shows we got to react to
and we're loyal them just as much as
we're low to our subscribers over here
dick juggling act and I got a showdown
to record tomorrow
are you recording mark - yes you ever
strode Adam are you literally right
before you oh dude I had no idea oh my
god
we're gonna do great they rescheduled
yours and I was like cool I'll get
another week I was like oh weird they
took my time good don't worry about it
this is how the quirky mercs do it I
didn't have any time it starts ending so
yesterday I've been working off of like
four to five hours of sleep a night for
the last week and a half
you know the killers and so many other
things going on that I legally cannot
talk about it is gonna kill us don't
worry I had to literally do YouTube
editor on a video because I was like oh
muscles imagine this oh my god enough
ranting about John and Greg's anxieties
no I don't feel as bad now Yeah right
well we can both go in
[Music]
I feel so much better on off a half only
we get some sleep
it's just obviously Brad okay great this
looks bad
that's what the system looks like it's
the microbots from big here ps5 could be
anything I just want to be in this room
looks like those things you'll be her
face on yeah
doll mails
I don't know the song is but I want it I
do too the song can imagine watch that
saw the stream of how much hype there
would dissipation so where's the damn
cops there it is buddy up oh my
wow that's different looks like a
skyscraper that's like a building looks
like an Xbox
silence Wow
why is beautiful it's like a PC monitor
it looks like a billion different looks
like a were louder that modern piece
yeah router router was that was that an
Ethernet jack USB doh now knock it over
and show me on its side it was really
cool
mmm-hmm does it come in black who think
of that like an inverted just one strip
of white down the middle like xbox
expense doesn't
[Music]
air fans closer look at my pants ooh oh
[Music]
it's there's no describe God
oh the digital edition one with no
destroy this pathetic God's your porch
yeah y'all livin in the past expensive
ass dis look we know it's gonna cost too
much you never had a media remote for
any of these consoles and the main
reason I got a ps3 initially before I
was really diving back into gaming was
not very games or just to have a blu-ray
and in case I want her to play this is
the most affordable and probably best
blu-ray on the market yeah that looks
absolutely beautiful router you nailed
it really does man yeah can't believe
they made it out of all those
microscopic balls see real footage of
how they make these in the factory I
wish I had a little bit more detail into
life to the insides of the magetta
select it yeah how much memory is in
this thing how powerful is the processor
what kind of outlets are we looking at I
mean I'm sure that information is there
somewhere online probably you can just
read a brief I'm sure there's a youtuber
out there may be several at this point
who's already done like a crap ton of
brain everything you've missed inside of
this announcement video is all new but
it does look night it seems like
PlayStation you know they've gone in the
opposite direction because usually
everything was very black and now it's
you know predominantly white and yeah
the controller does look kind of like I
wanna say something that's right there's
a metaphor here that's white light
overpowering black is that you think of
this what's happening here and this
represents right police sorry come here
for the commentary political over
console reveal its right there's so much
symbolism
digital console here's how dumb I am I
forgot what game it was I think it was a
recent Final Fantasy game Olivia me she
wanted to play the new Final Fantasy
game featuring frequent rejects guests
from the past before we moved
significantly further away and she got
busy with her life was looking to touch
Brianna white strange ripple gaming who
is killing her right now in way more
ways than one
illah net at being in final fantasy
season final she's one of the main
characters in Final Fantasy 7 and my
girlfriend wanted to play it she's like
a pre-order like damn how were you able
to pre-order it and she's like oh you
just download it what you can yeah I
thought it was only like really old
games yeah I realize you can get brand
new games and if you didn't want to wait
for the they want to own the disc you
can just tell her to digitally that's
probably how it started it's just giving
you the option and then eventually ever
since Apple took the disk drives out of
their computers I feel like we're slowly
getting to that diskless future because
I mean there's been games were like
where we were hanging out and or we had
people over and we're just downloading
old games and am i playing it together
or reversing each other and stuff I
didn't realize you could do that that's
that's literally how dumb I am
I had no idea you could do that with
like newer games like oh wait forever
for the Last of Us - yeah right look out
all you need is that compatible or be
able to back it up though like that's
the big thing about it yeah you know you
need you know saving space I don't know
how that works out because I don't know
if you're accessing a program that lives
in a cloud or something like that that
just saves your specific memory your
specific game path to your console
blu-rays like a single layer of allure
it's like over 50 gigabytes so like it
these games have to be huge obvi some of
the real rejects or biggest passions and
movies they made videos literally these
last couple killers we've really
underlined it reject party we're just
like let's figure this out in the middle
of the commentary yeah I love the
feeling of owning a game of life I like
that more than owning blu-rays weirdly
like looking at the game collection I
have substantially yeah there's so
differently exactly yeah there's
something more special about popping in
the disc and playing
I hold in my hands a hundred hours not
just two and a half and then scratching
it or not being able to play it anymore
but you could download an awesome but
yeah the one with the worry could we use
the dislike the regular ps5 console
that's gonna cost a crap ton of money
whereas the freaking digital one will
still cost you a lot of money but it's
really not gonna be as much yeah that's
cool that you get two different options
yeah and then you'll get folks like me
who just need those discs yeah just in
case but it s spent so much money I get
in the console that's gonna be a long
time before you get an extra this well
that's the thing I start to wonder too
is because I think at a certain point
during ps4 they stopped being backward
compatible and I don't know if that's
just because you know you make so many
iterations of one system me looking at
this I'm like oh PS five well I'll get
the disc one because I still have mostly
ps3 games in terms of what's recent but
then if there's aren't gonna actually
even work with the machine then it's
like almost yeah this is for whatever is
left over from ps4 and like the couple
games maybe that'll only come out on
physical or something like that looking
back at this trailer I mean everything
looks so beautiful like the headset the
HD camera looks great I wonder think you
just plug that into this computer camera
looks great I like the new designs of
the controllers it does I don't know if
I'm like because I don't know what the
community is like DC versus Marvel with
the PlayStation vs Xbox is it like that
you're gonna scrap of that because yeah
this looks like a hyper to PlayStation
meets Xbox at the same time this oh I
couldn't help but think about this and
I'm surprised I'm waiting this late in
the commentary to bring it up this is
the future this looks like the future
yeah this looks like when they had
teaser viral videos for the umbrella
corporation in the Resident Evil and
that's the thing bagging in like the 80s
and 90s like a future lighting used to
be like dark orange red now it's all
blue it does look incredibly sleek and
it's funny too because their controller
okay their controller I remember the one
time they drastically tried to redesign
and it was this big silver boomerang
looking thing and everybody responded
really poorly and then for ps3 I think
that was they literally just use the
same control tablet and ps4 the same
thing
same thing so it seems like that
controllers tried-and-true yeah I can
see what you're saying with the Xbox in
this with the disk version especially
because it does create that like you
know flowy kind of a beveled thing that
that does but I really like the look of
it at least at the outset I mean I'm
curious to see how long it'll stay
looking futuristic because especially
since ps4 this is a big change because
ps4 is just like a rhombus brick was
right what's funny about this in the
middle of that joke I got a notification
here about an article literally article
just notification Stephen Amell under
attack by racism accusers anywho that's
a side story that I will not be covering
haha guys are you excited for this
system let me know describe the rejects
click the notification bell look at you
guys soon